land und brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten morgen sicher guten morgen
markus wo erreiche ich dich versuchen
könnten kriminelle auf der yogamatte auf
der yogamatte völlig meditative
entspannung muss jetzt raus holen ja ich
klinge heute auch ein bisschen feierlich
ist ihr klar dass das heute unsere
fünfzigste folge ist die wir ja
aufnehmen ja dass ich nicht 40 folgen
podcast und ich ich ich finde irgendwie
sehr schön das ist eine schöne
geschichte ich habe gedacht so was was
ist der teil meiner arbeit haben im
moment mit am meisten spaß macht das
sind wirklich ist der austausch mit dir
tatsächlich ja das wunderbar das freut
mich also du weißt ja es gibt viele tage
an denen ich gar nicht reden also so
wenig so wenig wie möglich vor allem
dann wenn ich intensiv an büchern
scheibe und dadurch gibt es viele tage
wo ich mit niemandem so viel reden wie
mit dir auch wenn das seine
lebensgefährtin hört ja das stimmt dass
es gibt auch tage wo ich mir mehr rede
aber es gibt auch das gegenteil ja
herrlich und wirst du auch ständig
gefragt ob wir jetzt befreundet sind und
jahren wieder in der brecht so privat
ist und so hab ich werde aber hand aufs
herz
ja ja wie du denn so privat wäre ist
wirklich ja ja und dann muss ich immer
sagen ich war noch nie bei dir zu hause
und du noch nie bei mir ja wir waren
noch nie in unserem zuhause gegenseitig
so und was sagst du denn dann eigentlich
naja ich beschreibe wie das ist also ich
verschreibe dass es spaß macht
zusammenzuarbeiten so gibt es unter uns
in manchen dingen mit halben worten
verstehen dass wir in anderen ligen
bekanntermaßen unterschiedlich ansicht
haben das natürlich super ist für den
podcast dass man sich mit jedem podcast
ein stückchen mehr kennen lernt ja und
natürlich dass das verhältnis durch
sympathie getragen ist wenn das nicht so
wäre könnten wir das was wir hier machen
noch gar nicht machen und das stimmt
aber du gibst du eine olaf scholz
antwort eigentlich na ja ich gebe ich
schon deswegen weil unbekannte mich
fragen ich mich frage warum sollten die
das so genau wissen
ja aber die leute interessiert dass ich
werde auch immer gefragt wie du so bist
und so
und ob ich dich näher kenne und ob wir
befreundet sind das wollen die leute
wissen und ich weiß da nicht so richtig
der antwort weil ich also ich würde mal
sagen wir sind jetzt so in summe in so
einer übergangsphase ja also ja also in
der die voraussetzung für befreundete
das normalerweise ja dass man von dem
anderen irgendwie auch den inner circle
kommt und das ist provinzial sozusagen
der punkt zu dem es nie gekommen ist ja
das ist glaube ich wichtigen
unterschieden und dann ist es ja auch so
jeder mensch geht er mit dem begriff
freund anders um und ich reserviere den
bislang auf ganz wenige leute die ich
schon sehr lange kenne und wie viele
freunde hast du was du zu sagen mir ja
ich würde sagen also sechs vielleicht
sei es jetzt wo ich wo ich jetzt
wirklich sagen würde ohne mit der wimper
zu zucken freund ist der richtige
begriff
und da gehören dann aber auch schon
mindestens zwei oder drei zu wo ich sage
die kenne ich die 3 die kenne ich seit
30 jahren denken
noch aus einer solinger zeit wie jetzt
oder
tatsächlich ist einer dabei den kenne
ich aus meiner so was macht ja ja der
hat chemie studiert und wir haben in
einer wg zusammen gefunden ok und
ehrlich ich muss sagen das war mit
sicherheit die coaches so lustigste zeit
meines lebens
na ja also ich würde sagen sie war nicht
so richtig reif ja so was die
praktischen die menschenleben angehören
so ständig angst telefon hört abgestellt
oder sache dieser wohnung praktisch
funktioniert überhaupt gar nichts da
aber hat wir haben unglaublich viel spaß
miteinander gehabt und in so einer
prägenden zeit und man zu anfang mitte
20 ist und die welt entdeckt und die
großstadt entdeckt und so weiter also
das ist jetzt fast fast uns für unser
ganzes leben zusammengeschweißt hat und
ich freue mich heute noch riesig wenn
ich ihn sehe wir sehen uns nicht so oft
weil er nicht in der nähe wohnt aber es
ist immer wieder das ist so warm dass
man wie gesagt wird man versteht sich
nicht nur mit halbem mancher mit viertel
worten ja oder man noch eine ganz kleine
anspielungen bei dem anderen geht es
sofort ein ganze ganzer kostenlos von
vorstellungen und erinnerungen und das
ist natürlich das was eine freundschaft
zusammen schmiedet wenn man dann
tatsächlich das kann man jetzt sagen so
durch dick und dünn gegangen ist und
guckst du dann auch manchmal so ein
bisschen wehmütig melancholisch zurück
eigentlich wenig naja ich wenig jetzt
erst liegt ja in meinem bekannten
problem das ich nicht merke wie alt ich
bin ich denke es liegt ja noch gar nicht
so weit zurück so in meiner vorstellung
es hat irgendwie so eine starke
kontinuität und gerade wenn ich diesen
freund sehe dann habe ich das gefühl wir
sind wieder genau so albern wie damals
und es ist eigentlich gar keine zeit
vergangen
ja also dieses ich glaube ist ein trick
der biologie ich glaube wir gefühlt sind
wir immer so 27 oder 28
aber wenn du dann ein spiegel guckt
merkst du schon dass ein bisschen später
ist aber diese melancholie ja so
zurückzudenken an diese zeit und das hat
man doch gerade finde ich wenn man alte
freunde trifft ich weiß ich war mit
meinem cousin bin ich mal mit motorrad
bis nach griechenland gefahren da
reichen wie 16 oder 17 um eine meine
mutter hatte keine ahnung davon wie weiß
bis heute nicht dass ich heimlich mit
motorrad nach griechenland gefahren bin
und da sind wir damals auch nach in
skopje sind wir liegen geblieben war ist
um 1 kopie wie ich noch mal durch
schweinezucht mit dem erlass express wir
sind in skopje liegen geblieben und dann
hat uns ein orthodoxer mündlich hat uns
dann rausgeholt haben dann bei dem im
kloster dort irgendwie übernachtet und
es war das motorrad war eine moto guzzi
der legendäre modul eine coole maschine
fahren wäre ich nicht nein ich war nie
mein cousin der ist ein bisschen älter
und hat mich einfach mitgenommen günther
liebe grüße und er stellte er und der
und dann war die moto guzzi halt ich
weiß es gab schon zum berg dann sind wir
hoch gefahren in einer unfassbaren
gluthitze und plötzlich war das tippen
im eimer oder anstand meter mitten in
griechenland ohne moto guzzi ohne kohle
ohne alles ja und dann war sie markiert
dann gemacht was auch persönlich wieder
anfangen eine sehr gute nicht wirklich
ja kinder auf die stadt ist war mittags
und befohlen auf diesem berg hoch und es
waren gefüllt 45 grad und plötzlich
stand die moto guzzi einfach nur noch
eine ecke und dann kamen wir zu diesem
kloster und es kam dieser männlich und
der hat uns dann vermittelt an einen
sehr dubiosen mechaniker
der mechaniker konnte kein wort englisch
und wir eigentlich in wahrheit auch
nicht deswegen war die verständigung im
wie sehr schwierig und um ganz klar zu
machen dass er ein ersatzteil brauchte
das aus athen eingeflogen werden musste
machte er folgendes geräusch
wir haben erst gar nicht verstanden was
macht also eine handbewegung dazu und es
war er wollte uns sagen pass auf da
kommt ein flugzeug
konnte
es dauerte lange bis wir mitgekriegt
haben was er wirklich meint und dann
haben uns weiß ich noch das ist glaube
ich fünf tage lang einfach nur von
wassermelonen ernährt es gab halt sonst
nichts und als dann endlich die machen
doch was mit einer niederlage was man
entschieden hat sich sein herrlich
herrlich entschlackt ja so oder so ein
bisschen leer
also wir hatten hunger werden hohen
wassermelonen ist nicht viel drin aber
es war halt auch wirklich schön es war
so frei was auch immer so diese
existenzangst wie geht es jetzt weiter
wie teuer ist der neuen vergaser und wie
teuer wird dieses teil das mit diesem
geräusch hinterlegt war
das war die frage und irgendwann kann
dieses teil und als wir das dann bezahlt
hat mit der letzten kohle war so pleite
dass wir dann auch keinen urlaub mehr
machen konnten und sind dann in
igoumenitsa direkt auf die fähre und ich
weiß noch wie die frau am schalter
fragte welche kabine wir haben wollten
und dann sagte mir wie teuer sind die
denn die kostet eigentlich nix und
gesagt nichts ist aber auch noch immer
zu teuer für uns und dann haben wir uns
oben an deck einfach hingelegt das war
die aller günstigste mit
reisemöglichkeit und ich habe den fehler
gemacht genau im schatten dieses
schornsteins dieses schiff schornsteins
zu liegen und nachts flogen dann immer
so kleine kohle blockieren sofort vom
von schweröl flogen dann da aus dem
kreis der große partikel ja und landete
genau auf uns und unseren schlafsäcken
und dann ging es immer um die frage
nahrungsaufnahme
und ich weiß noch wie gingen runter
diese schiffs kantine in dieses so
genannte restaurant lisa faires war der
abgewrackte faire und da gab es
spaghetti mit tomatensoße und das war zu
teuer für uns und dann bin ich zu der
frau hin und habe mit ihr verhandelt was
spaghetti ohne tomatensoße kosten
man wirklich spreche die ohne tomaten
kann das gewicht
fällt ja nicht auch dass man die
intensivsten lustigsten und zusammen
schmieden erlebnisse immer in einer zeit
gemacht hat als man zu wenig geld hatte
ja ist es absolut wahr ist absolut war
ja ja weil man sich mit geld immer gegen
solche situationen mehr oder weniger
absicherung ja eigentlich eigentlich
kommt dann so die langeweile ins leben
auf eine art und ja also das ist erhalte
man gewinnt die sicherheit genau und es
ist ja auch bei vielen abenteuern so
dass im nachhinein lustiger sind
es ist die art von urlaub die erst
hinterher schön
das geht manchmal auch für hoch
strapaziöse exotischen reisen und soja
dass man gegen man sich dann nachher
wieder so ein kaminfeuer 20 30 jahre
später noch erwärmt ja und dann ist
dieser regenwald auch wenn man
unglaublich schön und alle mücken sind
in der fantasie aus dem vorstudie ja
oder um diese stamme die in der
feuchtigkeit nie wieder zu geheilt ist
total die strapazen vom aufstieg war
lange auf den philippinen bergregenwald
und so weiter im nachhinein ist das
alles so dermaßen schön da ist so ein
zuckerguss über die erinnerungen gibt
total aber ich weiß in der situation
wenn man ganz ehrlich zu sich ist das
war nicht einfach nur schön ich habe
etwas was mir gerade einfällt weil du
sagst philippinen und regenwald umso du
weißt wer wer ein richtig harter
reisender ist bis anton hofreiter
sehen wir beide ja sehr schätzen weil er
so unverstellt ist und so kantig und
irgendwie so echt und anderen hofreiter
kann der unfassbar interessante
geschichten erzählen wie er der biologe
und er war viele monate allein im
dschungel in peru glaub ich unterwegs
und hat sich dann dort das bein
gebrochen so habe ich das in erinnerung
und sah dann zu wie dieses bein immer
dunkler violetta und am ende schwarz
wurde und hat sich dann mit einem
gebrochenen bein tage lang durch den
tunnel geschleppt bret hart und er wäre
sonst der mehr drauf gegangen war allein
im dschungel unterwegs
das richtige hartz iv war jan sicht ganz
hart und diese uhr kraft die ihn anton
hofreiter drittligisten jetzt wie
insolvenz
hätte man nicht leonardo dicaprio
sondern anton hofreiter nehmen müssen
dann wäre es authentischer geholfen
großartig für dich auch und ich fürchte
anderen hofreiter sowieso seit unserem
letzten gespräch mit anton hofreiter
damit völlig neuen über anton hofreiter
mir völlig neuen augen du sagtest da war
fast schon aus das tut zu mir gesagt
weißt du anderen hofreiter funktioniert
nur mit diesen langen haaren
wir haben mit langen haaren ich hätte
dann der in der csu ja ja das stimmt das
stimmt hält es ist großartig und das
wird ja immer wie ein widerspruch wenn
jemand mit einer frisur wie anton
hofreiter ja über panzer und haubitzen
redet dass das wird ja irgendwie wie
soll man da sagen ein bisschen schräg
auch ja ja der sieht ja immer noch aus
wie der wehrdienstverweigerer
schlechthin ja der verboten aber wenn er
jetzt kurze haare hätte ja dann könnte
er auch viel panzerkommandant aussehen
wer so lang wäre das eine ganz andere
nummer ja somit die sich bayerischen
akzent
jaja könnte man sicher feldwebel
vorstellen oder so also die haare
gehören das schon zu deswegen egal wie
dünn sie werden da werden die räte
resthaar verwaltungen beta betrieben und
die werden weiter gepflegt und geht ich
habe mit anton hofreiter damals auch
darüber gesprochen sagte es doch
gefährlich leuchtender pfad und sonne im
dschungel in peru unter meinte er die
die trifft man daten zeigt wie jetzt mit
eher ja hätte dann irgendwann hätte so
ein gangster truppe getroffen
die wollten ihn überfallen und und
vielleicht auch umbringen und dann ist
er ganz nah an mich herangetreten und
reißt die augen auf und sagt aber da
habe ihm klar gemacht der ist jetzt mit
mir nicht läuft
dann habe ich ihn dann hab ich zu ihm
gesagt erzählt wie wieder unter material
dieser anführer der war da ein 60 groß
er hat dieser der oper poster und
fuchtelte da somit messer vor ihm rum
und anton hofreiter sagte da bin ich
ganz nah an den trauen und da ist dem
klar gorny bringen
und dann habe ich gesagt aber hat er das
verstanden dass du ihn umbringen wollte
und dann guckt mich an und sagt das hat
er ganz genau verstanden
mit dieser mit diesem riesen fünf jahre
in die flucht geschlagen na ja mit
welchen kanal der liga sicher wird er
wiederkommen ist persönlich erdrosselt
aber herrlich und und das merkt man bei
ihm und ich habe mich immer gefragt
woher kommt dieses uhr wüchse gerne die
sehr urkraft und und dass das ist dass
das ist in anderen hofreiter drin und
deswegen irgendwie ich ich hab ich habe
eine schwäche für eindhoven zu weil ich
so leute mag dir einfach so unverstellt
und echt sind und dann auch sagen okay
ist mir bewusst ob mich die leute mögen
oder nicht mögen und ob ich den zu eckig
und so bayerisch und so lange her ich
bin es mir egal ich bleibt wie gut also
ich würde immer sagen das ist eine der
qualitäten die ich am allermeisten bei
politikern schätze ist wenn ihnen
relativ egal ist was die leute über sie
denken weil das natürlich von mir
berufsbeschreibung heer von jemand hier
wieder gewählt wird genau mit ziemlich
komplizierte sache extra braucht man
nerven wie drahtseile zu und auch schon
eine spezielle ausstrahlung damit genau
funktionieren naja aufgefallen meisten
können sich das nicht leisten die müssen
dann tatsächlich wie anton hofreiter ja
ein gesichtsausdruck machen können mit
dem man eine lokomotive aufhält wer
sonst funktioniert das nicht also jemand
wie gauweiler hat das irgendwie auch
hingekriegt und jemand gg sie vielleicht
haben nicht viele die das hinkriegen
karl lauterbach die die bleiben sich
selber treu es ist egal wie harter wind
von vorne kommt und der punkt ist
ich teile viele positionen von hofreiter
auch nicht mehr darum geht es gar nicht
aber es geht darum dass jemand einfach
konsistent bei dem bleibt was er sagt
und ralf stegner zum beispiel auch
vielfach angefeindet ist auch jemand den
ich genau dass dafür schätze kannst du
tausend mal in die debatte gehen der
zieht sein ding durch ja und das ist das
hat das verhalten ist nicht gefragt so
nach der anzahl der menschen die ich
meine freundin wie ist das bei dir so
ähnlich ich habe handvoll tatsächlich
handvoll mehr ist es wirklich nicht
vielleicht sogar noch weniger
und das sind dann auch leute die ich
ewig lange kenne und hat den neulich ein
schönes erlebnis tag an alte freunde aus
südtirol liebe grüße
die ja mit denen ich zur schule gegangen
bin usw
dort liegt die kann dann plötzlich nach
hamburg ist eine kleine truppe von von
jungs die immer
so steht der reisen machen für total
lustig ihrem klub und dann zahlen die da
immer geld ein und von diesem geld
verreisen die dann einmal im jahr
gemeinsam und ich fand das total witzig
und damit sie dann abendessen gehen wird
wird auch das essen aus der kohle der
clubkasse summen zeitschrift das
schweißt zusammen erwachsen teil
zusammen und es war irgendwie schön das
war so ein bisschen surreal ja die dann
sollen in meiner welt herz jesu in
hamburg so zu erleben und dabei auch
gleichzeitig so schön wir reden dann so
unseren dialekt und das ist und das ist
das was ich so mag es ist dann also es
sind alles wie früher ja alles
südtiroler findest das nicht interessant
dass man im rheder fallen hat seine
tiefsten freundschaften schließt solange
man noch ziemlich junges und das leben
nicht kennt und je älter und erfahrener
mann wird umso weniger freunde kommen
noch dazu aber was genau umgekehrt ist
jedenfalls war das bei mir so ich habe
in meiner jugend quasi keine
bekanntschaften geschlossen ja also
entweder jemand freund oder nicht
und so ist das ja so wenn man hier einem
die einem begegnen dass man eine
unglaublich hohe hürde errichtet hat ja
wer überhaupt eine chance hat freund zu
werden wogegen man auf der anderen seite
unglaublich leicht sehr sehr viele
bekannte bekommt es ist hat sich genau
umgedreht gegenüber früher und das liegt
wahrscheinlich daran dass so die der
anspruch geheime jemanden freund zu
nennen wenn jemand neu dazukommt
konkurrieren muss mit menschen die man
30 jahre kennt die man noch so von
früher als freunde hat wo man sagt diese
intensität kann man die als erwachsener
überhaupt herstellen ja weil weil weil
es ich glaube da kommt diese dieser
begriff der bedingungslosigkeit
irgendwie dazu die die wollen nichts von
dir die die sind einfach leute die waren
immer da mit denen bist du aufgewachsen
irgendwie weiß ich wenn ich an man
halten von mein haar zum beispiel denke
ja wissen dass wir sind erst zehn tage
älter als ich und das sind früher im
schneetreiben im wie morgens in der
dunkelheit zehn meter den berg hoch
geladen
allein durch den dunklen weil sowieso
kleine stöcke sie haben mit mit sechs
sieben acht jahren und so etwas schweißt
natürlich zusammen wenn du wenn du nie
genau weiß ob der böse wolf dann
vielleicht doch recht nicht in die ecke
kommt ja und es waren schöne momente
aber diese unbeschwertheit das ist
natürlich schon schön ich denke ja so
ein bisschen unbeschwertheit habe ich
auch heute noch aber ich hatte ja gerade
erzählt wie ich mit diesem frontal
zusammen gezogen wird in köln wir haben
auf ärztlicher straße gewohnt und die
zürcherstrasse die war kinder am
eisenberg bezüglich der dsw geht von
einer uni auswahl stehen die stadt zum
typischer platz ja aber sie haben den
vorderen teil richtung innenstadt
gewohnt dass das studio viertel durch
und du ja gewesen wurde dann in der zeit
also wir reden jetzt über die späten
achtziger und neunziger jahre und so
weiterhin sehr starker migranten zuzug
war auch abends auf der straße manchmal
ein bisschen unbehaglich und so weiter
also das war schon speziell und werden
in einem haus und ich habe eine richtige
senden werte aufgelegt in diese wohnung
zu kommen
da wohnt hier jemand da gab es nicht
eine große nachfrage habe ich mit
bisschen eingeschränkt bei ihm
und er hat ja stark psychische probleme
und danach auch die wohnung aus also man
muss sagen diese wohnung vermutlich ein
roadie haben einen fall in dem zustand
in dem ich da reingegangen bin also mein
freund war gar nicht dabei der welt er
nie eingezogen
er kannte die in diesem moment nicht
dann habe ich dann später davon erzählt
hat sich da unbedingt hin wollte und da
lagen zu 78 teppiche übereinander
schichten von teppichen das heißt dass
jeder der eingezogen war der hat den
teppich draufgelegt und dann hat mit
dieser stelle heißt du sie hören dieses
dieses alten kurhauses ein abgesägt und
damit die türen
und die die wende da waren also mehr als
zehn schichten tapeten und auf der
untersten schicht war das und mit
ölfarbe bemalt und dann mit so einem
wunderschönen hellblau und so einem
creme ton das war natürlich alles
komplett zerstört aber ich habe dann in
einem zimmer diese wende gelastet ja
weil ich die seitenwände das war so als
wenn man so es gibt so eine szene in dem
film der leopard von visconti da da ist
alle modelle mit claudia cardinale läuft
er durch im palast und spielen
verstecken und kommen dann in einen
riesigen teil des palastes die nicht
bewohnt wird und er ebenso 100 jahren
quasi nichts passiert und da sagt
claudia cardinale sag mal die viele wie
viele räume hatten eigentlich dieser
fahrgast und alonso weiß ich nicht habe
das muss doch dann in dein onkel muss
doch wissen gehört ja da sagte mein
onkel würde niemals ein palast bewohnt
in dem er alle zimmer ketten
und ich hatte diese szene vor augen
recht habe den film mit 20 gesehen und
wir haben mit 22 1 gezogen als ich diese
dieser krise fresken quasi sah ja in
dieser 60 quadratmeter wohnung und dann
habe ich als jemand der mit handwerk nie
etwas zu tun gehabt hat das alles
beigebracht und fußböden abgeschliffen
und so weiter und das ganze dann nachher
aus wie eine filmkulisse
ja da denkst du dir letzte tango in
paris oder so also so ein charakter hat
er das aber muss dazu sagen wir hatten
ein badezimmer und eine toilette die
aber nicht in der wohnung sondern auf
dem flur gott sei dank nur für uns
alleine
und da gab es kein waschbecken und ich
habe in dieser wohnung elf jahre ohne
waschbecken gelebt dafür war da eine
uralte badewanne mit füßen drin ja und
wenn man auf der toilette saß konnte man
durch das kleine fenster dem ozean hatte
eine romantik ja also ich irgendwie die
schönste wohnung die ich hier gewohnt
habe und jetzt kommt das wichtigste
thema freundschaft wir beide haben da
gewohnt und in diesem ganzen haus war
nur coole typen bis auf uns
also unter mir wohnte ein architekt ja
der sat eins zu eins aus wie jack
nicholson und benahm sich auch so er
hatte also in der anfangszeit ein
frauenverschleiß ja wir fühlten uns wie
die schul jux daneben also wir haben
dort nur gehorcht quasi
anteilen derweil der hatte er hatte ja
auch sein sein bart auf dem flur und
wohnte dann mit dem ein oder anderen
mittelbar über den flur über ja und alle
worte und trug die und warf die
jungtiere machen dass unsere szenen war
konnte ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
unten wohnte ein kölsch vertrag tja also
ein asi mit glatze ja und
ja der damit seiner sind die frau
zusammen lebte ja die bestimmt mal sehr
hübsch gewesen war aber die beiden
machten sich das leben zur hölle
wirklich unglaublich zur hölle und er
war auch wenn er getroffen hatte und das
hat er jeden tag nicht ungefährlich und
über uns ein ganz cooler tanz schon
lässt also zehn jahre älter und auch so
wolf der schon viel schnee gesehen hat
so ganz abgebrüht und cool also alle
nahmen uns nicht ernst und
ich meine ganze vorstellen dass ihr
damals aber die wir waren aus dem lachen
nicht heraus kamen ja wir waren
eigentlich ständig überfordert aber
diese überforderung die hat uns auch
zusammengeschweißt ja total das ist ja
das ist ja das was ich meine auch mit
dieser freiheit also ich musste ganz
ehrlich sagen ich wenn man auch solche
geschichten gehört die
htc lange verhandlungen über spaghetti
ohne tomatensoße und soja das klingt
jetzt im nachhinein irgendwie lustig und
gesang exotisch aber in der situation
was natürlich überhaupt nicht lustig und
ich wenn ich daran zurückdenke so die
die die dass das leben war schon echt
ein harter kampf und und diese
existenzangst die sich dann irgendwann
so in so einem großhirn rein frisst ja
und fräst geht nicht so schnell weg das
ist das ist uns interessanter punkt ich
weiß nicht wie das wie das bei dir ist
aber ich weiß dass das ein gefühl ist
dass viele viele menschen teilen
selbst wenn dein kopf die irgendwann mal
sagt deine ratio die gesagt pass auf und
vielleicht auch dann banker der sagt du
was auf das kriegen wir hin ja die miete
kriegen wir hin wie bezahlt und einmal
am tag warm essen ist auch drin und so
entspann dich mal dass rational zu
wissen ist die eine sache aber ist
wirklich zu fühlen ist noch mal eine
ganz andere sache der hat man denke doch
mal an die kriegsgeneration jan ihren in
ihren eigenheimen saß und so weiter
erfolgreiche karriere gemacht hatten und
ganze keller ja die immer noch voll
waren mit mit mit notversorgung
das war damals in der szene kein
klopapier aber vielleicht eine million
einmachgläser und was alles so gelagert
war eine fremde die angst dass der
mangel wieder kommen könnte der sich
fast bis in die gene reingefressen
aber er war unbedingt in unseren
freundschafts thema zu bleiben was ich
auch feststelle ist das heute
freundschaft in der jungen generation
einen höheren wert hat als in unserer
familie auch nicht die einzelne
freundschaft ja also ein guter freund
ist ein guter freund aber dass man sagt
da gehe ich nicht hin ich will nicht in
die andere stadt und so weiter wenn ich
habe hier meine freunde genau und das
wäre für mich kein kriterium gewesen und
ich meine ich hätte auch niemanden
erkannt meinem ganzen umfeld der gesagt
hätte hätte dem guten job nicht
angenommen aus angst seine freunde zu
verlieren und zum beispiel dieser freund
von dem ich gerade gesprochen habe wir
wurden quasi dadurch auseinandergerissen
dass der in der schweiz behauptete roche
einen guten posten gekriegt hat so und
dann war schluss mit der schönen kölner
zeit
heute weiß ich nicht ob man das nicht
anders machen würde und dann sagen würde
ja vielleicht wird ja bei bayer
demnächst was frei da kann ich ja hier
bleiben oder sohn also ich glaube heute
würde sich das denken stärker verändern
und sagen da der wert von freundschaft
der ist so hoch und dann musste noch
überlegen heute kannst ihr mit freunden
jederzeit und überall kommunizierten
liegt trotzdem werte auf sie zu sehen
früher hat man seine freunde nach 18 uhr
angerufen
bevor es long distance calling
irgendwann ihr einziger ja das war und
ferngespräche die waren teuer kann man
sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen aber
tagsüber hat man meistens nicht
telefonieren genau und warum ganz wenig
telefonieren genau das heißt man nannte
leute seine guten freunde die man einem
mit dem man einmal im monat telefoniert
hat das ist ja auch völlig anders heute
sind die allgegenwärtig man sich die
auch auf dem smartphone
wenn man miteinander telefoniert über
facetime und so weiter dass ich so viel
präsenter und
trotzdem ist es so dass man sagt hier
habe ich meine peergroup habe ich meine
leute meine paradies und so weiter ich
gehe nicht nur einfach irgendwo hin nur
wegen einem job ja ja es ist wahr ich
war gerade telefonieren sagt ist das
kann sich heute kaum mehr vorstellen das
war ja damals es war eine ziemliche
sensation um das war teuer wie du sagst
und ich weiß nicht ob ich schon mal
erwähnt habe dass ich habe beim militär
in der appell war und ich habe dort eine
sehr lustige geschichte erlebt der
ganzen war ist beim militär in ihr habt
ja ja ja es waren einmal ausführlicher
gab's da gab es auf dem kasernenhof
standen drei telefonzellen und abends
war so der moment nehmen dann wieder
nach hause telefoniert ja und es vor
zwei dieser telefonzellen war nie
irgendeiner und auch innen drin war
keiner und vor einer war eine mörder
schlange
und ich bin natürlich ein lehrer
rainhard einmal der deponie hießen die
dinge eher die chips dj toni rhein
geworfen und dort geborgen und nach
südtirol zu telefonieren und druck weil
die kohle weg und dann habe ich
irgendwann mal ein freund von mir
gefragt - sie hatte mit den mit dem ich
damals sehr befreundet war seit liegen
uns einfach warum stehen ich immer was
ist hier los sagte ja nicht irgendwann
mal und irgendwann habe ich dann das
geheimnis dieser telefonzelle erfahren
solle
teelöffel versorgt und zwar die
telefonzelle gingst du rein und dann
passierte folgendes zum nimmt den hörer
von der gabel dann wählte drei mal ganz
schnell hintereinander in einem in einer
bestimmten grundgeschwindigkeit die
11 runter wieder zurückzog 113 mal
hintereinander die 1 und dann nimmst du
den hörer ab und in dem moment wo
sozusagen das besetztzeichen kommen
sollte ballast du mit aller wucht auf
diese gabel drauf ja du hast den hörer
in der hand willst du willst du willst
diese 1 und in dem moment wo weil drei
mal 1 keinen sinn ergibt dieses
besetztzeichen kommen sollte in einer
ganz bestimmten nanosekunde house to mit
wumms auf diese kabel darauf ja so
bonbon so war das runter und dann kam
ein freizeichen und dann konntest du
telefon unbegrenzt wohin du wolltest
will
spektakulär ich weiß dann hast du dich
stundenlang in dieser telefonzelle
angestellten der e3 nach hause zu
technik und freunden zu telefonieren
genauso war es genau herrlich und ich
ich ich es war irre da standen immer
massen von menschen vor dieser
telefonzelle fragt mich nicht wie
neapolitaner sind ja so lebenskünstler
wie die das rausgekriegt haben aber da
ich frage mich wer hat das als erster
erforscht ich hab keine ahnung ich
vermute irgendein ein angestellter von
der staatlichen telefongesellschaft
irgendein techniker irgendeinem von
denen war das wahrscheinlich klar und
ich sage mal neapolitaner werden nicht
mehr politiker wenn sie das nicht sofort
erfahren hätten und das tag noch
vergeben weil wann immer die chance
besteht dem staat sozusagen ein ein
schnippchen zu schlagen macht man's auch
hast du denn in der militärzeit freunde
gewonnen linus war zum beispiel so einer
mit dem ich sehr sehr befreundet war hat
mich dann hat mich danach so mitgenommen
so inso quartiere in der appell ja da
gibt es zum teil seien keine namen mehr
bei den straßen da war ich gefährlich da
reinzugehen es gab mal ihre geschichte
der wollen die neapels straßen ohne
namen ja damals war das royale zwei ich
weiß nicht ob es die heute noch gibt
aber nah dran müssen aber unter
da im dunkeln
da wusste sie sehr ganz engen gassen da
wusste jeder wohin musste unter wurden
wurden im großen aber der postbote also
daher kannte die familie niederrhein ich
halte die familien das richtige wort ist
der herforder die camorra der minister
wir waren alle weg schließt da ja es ist
ein text von der er fordert er die
kannten sich alle und da gab's da wurden
im großen stil wurden dort
geschmuggelte zigaretten vorzugsweise
marlboro gehandelt
und das heißt man kriegt ihr dort
stangen von zigaretten also riesige
batterien voller von zigarettenstangen
stangen zigaretten die dort so unter der
hand verkauft wurden für ganz kleines
geld am staat vorbei und da gab es einen
vorfall wird dass das wäre für die haben
dann bei touristen vorzugsweise die sich
daran erinnert haben haben sie dann den
haben sie dann nochmal die die spezial
stange untergejubelt spezial stange war
eine stange zigaretten mit vermeintlich
weil sie nicht zehn 15 20 packungen
marlboro da drin aber tatsächlich war es
so die waren präpariert also vorne war
eine packung drin hinten war eine
packung drin dass wir schon sägemehl
ähnliches spezifisches gewicht ja das
merkst du nicht dass gekauft hast und
das ding nicht sofort auf gemacht hast
bist du voll drauf reingefallen das
heißt du bezahlst eine volle stange
marlboro und kriegst danach oder
vertretern der politischen chemiker jahr
auszutragen was das gleiche chemische
gewicht hat 420 parken im kindertreff
von zigaretten oder ganz ein mann aus
dem trentino der ist genau auf die
nummer 1 gefallen hat offenbar mehrere
dieser stangen gekauft kam nach hause
nach trient und hat dort diese
zigaretten auf gemacht und festgestellt
dass sägemehlring und wurde dann so
sauer dass er sich in zug gesetzt hat
nach neapel zurückgefahren ist hunderte
kilometer hat den typen gesucht und
hatte ihn an ort und stelle erschossen
ihre geschichte wir sind in diesen
gassen diesem schmuggler gast
internation ich damals unglücklich war
ja es war spannend und ich eine militär
freund ja genau mit und dann darf man
sagen so herrlichen die sind auf den
vesuv hoch werden aber du hast keine
leeren politikerinnen oder so
kennengelernt die dein herz erwärmt hat
keine folge also da will da gab es diese
schönen parkplätze da gab es diese autos
das gibt es glaube ich noch heute
italiener haben ja so kleine wohnungen
und alone am zweifelsfall die mama auch
noch extremer flüchten so genau und dann
und angab stand einer dieser autos alle
mit so abgeklebten scheiben und so
weiter und sie sehr beschlagene scheiben
auch und so also da wurde sozusagen
einer gewissen körperlichen tätigkeit
ist man danach gegangen ich habe in der
statistik gelesen hat sich mein buch
über die liebe geschrieben habt dass das
land in europa das den wenigsten verkehr
vor der ehe hat italien ist mit das
halte ich für ein gerücht mit blick auf
meine vergangenheit an yahoo asta die
quote hoch getriebe ich nicht ich hab
das da beobachtet hallo ich war da ja
das ist tatsächlich durch soziale
umstände erklärbar dass sie keine eigene
bilder haben und so noch zu hause wohnen
und bisschen katholische sexualmoral
jeder noch aktien soweit also gerade
katholische sexualmoral nicht apple aber
wer den anderen ecken italien kommen wo
ein wille da ein gebüsch würde ich mal
sagen ja okay also das sehe ich ein
bisschen anders ich habe da hatte ich
wirklich meine vielleicht mal die
statistik ja auch irgendwie gefällt
jener lügen wenn sie ja bitte dich ich
meine wenn du wenn du sowas stell dir
vor du gehst jetzt bis auf der straße
unterwegs und da kommt jetzt von
marktforscher um die ecke und sagen sie
mal haben sie eigentlich heimlich 6 was
sagst du gibst du dann eine ehrliche
antwort oder danach noch ihren namen
ihre telefonnummer und helmut euro wie
auch gleich an
im leben nicht aber ich würde gar keine
antwort geben jeder der mir ist meine
ich raus denken sondern ich würde gar
keine jedoch das meine ich doch also ich
glaube nicht so viel gelogen wie bei dem
thema und es ist auch gratis muss doch
auch haben ja ok man kann also sozusagen
der statistik erkennen welcher nation am
stärksten übertreiben ja möglich haben
meistens übrigens nur gute aussage über
sex statistik also wenn du eine größe
von geschlechtsorganen und
regelmäßigkeit und wie oft mit ihrer
frau in der woche und so weiter dann
kann man dieser statistik einzig und
allein ist neben ja welche nationen das
größte bedürfnisse haben anzugeben und
welche nicht so groß sagt ja und ich
glaube das ist alles was man auch ich
sehe immer dass in diesen statistiken
franzosen auftauchen ganz vorne
tatsache ja also das lese ich immer
wieder ich glaube ich glaube das ist ein
bisschen dem eigenen image irgendwie
entsprechen ich glaube ja das glaube ich
auch weil der franzose denkt dass die
anderen franzosen weil er ja auch an das
image glaubt auch so hohe zahlen dass
man sich dann daran beteiligen muss ja
und dann schaukelt sich sowas
wechselseitig wer genau so entstehen
dann quasi schwammen grüßen ja
aber sagt glaubst du richard das wird es
noch mal vergleichen also ich meine
diese geschichte erleben noch junge
leute heute natürlich auch im natürlich
ja logischerweise ich ja doch aber was
anders ist ist und hoffentlich erleben
sie aber was anders ist ist tatsächlich
dieses dieses sehr wie soll man sagen
gehabt dieser pfad dieser geplante
pfarreien so ins berufsleben dass das
nämlich immer als ehrlich gesagt als
wahnsinniges defizit war also dieses
dieses lästige so mal gucken was aus uns
wird und verhalten doch gar nicht aber
gibt es nicht gibt s nicht trotzdem also
ja das ist sogar ihre eltern das ist
rock'n'roll
beten die statistiken rund ansagen was
aufwändig das studieren dann werde ich
mit sophie prozent wahrscheinlichkeit in
soundsoviel zeit einen job haben und
werde in diesem job im zweiten jahr mit
soundso viel prozent wahrscheinlichkeit
so und so viel verdienen und das finde
ich gruselig dass nur die eine seite das
ist gruselig aber ist die eine seite die
andere seite ist die die vorhin genannt
habt ja das kumpels freunde freundinnen
ja
eine bedeutung haben die riesengroß das
heißt also bei aller karriereplanung
nimmt man sich dafür aber eine menge
zeit
das stimmt ich meine sucht also dass der
entspricht jetzt nicht diesem bild der
stromlinienförmigkeit und das ist das
größte problem junger leute dass sie so
viele einander widersprechen die dinge
gleichzeitig bewerkstelligen müssen
runter sozusagen für sich geordnet
kriegen müssen das übrigens interessant
dieser dieser dieser wert von
freundschaft und ja auch familien
letzten endes eine der für diese jungen
generation so wichtig ist es gibt einen
englischen soziologen david willetts der
sagt das ist einer der gründe warum sie
weniger verdienen
weil sie nicht bereit sind einfach
sofort dem job hinterher zu ziehen
sondern sagen freundschaft ist mir
wichtiger ich verliere meine freunde ich
mache das nicht ich ziehe nicht mal eben
in die schweiz weil es dort ein bomben
job für mich gibt weil dann verliere ich
all diese sozialen kontakte oder sie
sehr interessant ich habe das auch immer
so laut ist und weil das natürlich eine
folge der wohlstandsgesellschaft ist
also das konnten sich frühere
generationen nicht sagen nein das ganz
ganz wichtig war überhaupt ein job zu
kriegen genau und ich kenne die
kehrseite davon also mein vater hat den
job kriegt in solingen da bin ich ja
deswegen geboren und aufgewachsen der
kam aus hannover und in hannover bewegte
der sich in einer hoch illustren szene
er hatte an der werkkunstschule design
studiert ja und in seinen freunden waren
schriftsteller und
spanien journalisten die nachher also
ihren fußabdruck in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik hinterlassen haben
theaterregisseure filmemacher aber ganz
viele künstler galeristen solche rollt
er kommt ja nach sony
rowling war im vergleich dazu
kultureller steppe ja das kann man
überhaupt nicht vergleichen und das war
für meinen vater überhaupt keine
artgerechte umgebung das heißt er hatte
eigentlich kaum noch freunde gefunden
naja so über jahre hinweg waren waren
arbeitskollegen eigentlich seinen
einzigen mehr oder weniger freunde das
ist ein schritt wo ich schon mit 20
gedacht hat hätte niemals machen sollen
das sagt er mir aber jetzt versetzt dich
mal in die welt anfang der
sechzigerjahre du hast einen beruf
gelernt den es nicht gibt kein mensch
weiß was ein designer ist ja und wer
kannst du froh sein wenn überhaupt
irgendwo im drop christ und das ist eben
heute in vielen bereichen anders in dem
moment wo man sich aussuchen kann und wo
man irgendwie aufspürt und weiß wie
wichtig der wert von freundschaft ist
verändern sich diese prioritäten also
ich wage mal die these noch nie war
freundschaft so bedeutsam für eine
gesellschaft wie in den
wohlstandsgesellschaften
und ist manches nicht auch nur die
illusion von freundschaft also wenn du
dann irgendwie mit kriegs das was sich
menschen mit wirklich ihren nur
allerengsten 2000 freundin dann
irgendwie geburtstag feiern ja die
gewinne würde ich auch hier gibt es
übrigens in der medienlandschaft auch
also ja der ein oder andere den ich hier
nicht nennen will einen der
wahrscheinlich 500 leute seine freundin
nennt oder sie wie freunde anspricht
also sowas gibt es tatsächlich
aber ich meine darüber reden wir hier
nicht mehr geredet jetzt wirklich über
über ihre über leute mit denen man
eigentlich gern jemand gerne jede woche
sieht und mit dem man einfach gerne
zusammen ist und ich denke da an oskar
waldner der mal gesagt hat freundschaft
ist weit tragischer als liebe sie dauert
länger ich will ich gerade so gibt es
vielleicht auch weil es sozusagen diese
ja diese diese sozialen zwänge natürlich
auch gibt ja also diese enorm hohen
mieten in städten und so weiter und
diese druck der da so kommt nun der ist
enorm
gibt es vielleicht auch eine neue
notwendigkeit für freundschaft aber hat
sich das ja dass die these ist
interessant aber ich würde man dazu
sagen als ich zum beispiel nach köln zog
ich hätte mir auch nicht alleine in
wohnung leisten können also der
unterschied ist einfach wer heute mit
dem studium beginnt hat im durchschnitt
deutlich mehr geld in der tasche durch
sein elternhaus als das in meiner
generation der fall war und in gleicher
relationen sind die mieten gestiegen ich
glaube das hat sich einfach nur von
höheren niveau eingependelt kann sagen
das war ja nicht früher so das ist also
bin ich mal guckte in meinem freundes
und bekanntenkreis und so gab die idee
in studentenwohnheimen erst mal gelebt
haben oder in wgs gelebt haben und das
kommt jetzt alles eben wieder na das ist
wieder genauso alle alles auf dem
höheren niveau weil die wg kostet heute
das dreifache von damals also diese
tolle wohnung da muss ich mal überlegen
in der zülpicher straße diese
heruntergekommene wohnung die kostete 5
150 mark für 60 quadratmeter
1989 anfang der neunziger jahre so das
ist wahrscheinlich von der kaufkraft
heute so viel wie vielleicht 600 oder
650 euro
dafür würde man die leute nicht mehr
kriegen im leben nicht im leben nicht
ich habe damals im kolpingheim in
münchen am karlsplatz stachus gelebt das
war ihre unterm dach in seiner noblen
lage kapsel kolping ja ganz in gold
genau das war interessant und das war
natürlich also das war das war hart aber
ich bin dem bis heute dankbar dass ich
da unterkriechen konnte aber es war
wirklich hart hat da mit einem
österreichischen raketenforscher
zusammengewohnt
ja ja der ist aber immer taxi gefahren
ich weiß nicht welcher vielleicht etwas
aus dem geworden weiß ich leider nicht
aber ich hatte in anderen sehr sehr
lieben freund auch österreicher auch
wiener ralf hatte auch als hatte so ein
bisschen besser erwischt so was so die
finanzielle grundausstattung angeht und
er hatte eine nette kleine wohnung mit
den schwaben und mit dem habe ich dort
wahnsinnig viel zeit verbracht und dann
sind wir auch manchmal nach und nach
wien gefahren dass das war schön
irgendwie man in diesem legendären u4
ich weiß nicht ob das kennst das schon
ganz legendärer wiener club und und es
gibt die die herrliche szene da waren
dann auch so die die österreichischen
popstars und so weiter alle unterwegs
und da kennst du die erv ja die eav die
die kenne ich rauf und runter die die
meistzitierte band in unserem podcast
ist die eav ja ja das hat aber es hat
damit zu tun ich mal ich mag die die
subversive dass da so drin ist kennst du
die geschichte von klaus eberhartinger
dem sänger der svp es ist sogar so
unserem blond gelockter mit somatischen
länder genauso sehr zufällig genau genau
und das sind ja das sind echt
ausgeschlafene jungs immer gewesen und
der hat mal hat eine anzeige bekommt von
jörg haider war weil er in einem
interview gesagt hat und er hat ist
dieser brauner orange ja ok ja und
darauf gehen gab es eine anzeige in von
jörg haider wegen beleidigung der volt
sich das nicht gefallen lassen brauner s
genannt zu werden und dann kannst du
eine gerichtsverhandlung und dann
stellte sich klaus eberhartinger hin und
hat dem richter klar gemacht dass das
jetzt gar nicht böse gemeint sei sondern
ihm sei aufgefallen dass jörg haider
immer so eine schöne bräune hätte und
der sei davon ausgegangen dass jörg
haider er regelmäßig ins solarium geht
deswegen sei er davon ausgegangen dass
auch an den braunen ohrstedt ja aber das
ganze unterstellt doch dass jörg haider
braunen als beleidigung und ich als
beleidigung empfunden hat oder ich hätte
gedacht hätte ja nicht nur über das
zweite aufgeregt ich habe keine ahnung
auf jeden fall endete es mit einem
freispruch für klaus wir warten ab
gleich ein junger durchgekommen aber
okay heute deswegen unter anderem mag
ich die erv und und ralf man mein freund
ralf auch wiener die wiener sind echte
originelle leute der der waren im im u4
es hat einmal erzählt oder gab es schon
so eine große herrentoilette ja da waren
diese ganzen diese ganzen urinale eins
nach dem anderen erst ein großer laden
und es begab sich eines späten abends
dass er dort stand um sich zu
erleichtern und nehmen ihm steht
plötzlich falco und
pinkelte auch und breit so wie ich ihn
auch kennen es die geschichte glaube ich
sofort dreht sich so lässig zu ihm und
die beiden stehen da und pinkeln und
reif sagt nur ernst sagt sina berühmter
und daraufhin sagt falko bartmuß
schiefen
die hat einmal erzählt und ich wenn du
wiener kannst wenn du weißt wie wiener
sind weißt du diese geschichte stimmt
was an so so so ja so so schöne
freundschaften bereich habe ich
irgendwann dann leider aus den augen
verloren vielleicht klappt's ja mal
wieder da könnte man direkt wieder
ansetzen weißt du bei dieser falco
geschichte das ist auch das schöne an
freundschaften dass man eigentlich egal
wie lang man sich nicht gesehen hat du
setzt eigentlich da wieder an wo du vor
25 jahren aufgehört hast du hast das
gefühl du hast gar nicht aufgehört naja
und neben diesen reden und sich mit
halben oder viertel worten verstehen
kann sich freundschaft noch dadurch
auszeichnen dass ich sagen würde meine
freunde sind die menschen mit denen ich
am liebsten zusammen schweige also dass
man auch große wanderungen macht der
freund über die nicht gesprochen habe
mit dem habe ich großartige wanderung
gemacht den usa national parks
wanderungen in südfrankreich in der
beton schlucht und da passiert immer
dasselbe am anfang redet man und redet
und redet und
irgendwann ergreift die natur vereinen
genau genommen ist und dann kann man
stundenlang einträchtig nebeneinander
her wandern ohne das bedürfnis zu haben
miteinander zu reden - wenn dann
irgendwann offenbar gipfel sitzt oder
sowas und das dann zu erleben und das
gemeinsam geschafft zu haben und dann
einfach nur gemeinsam zu schweigen
ja das kann manchmal sogar noch
verbinden dasein als miteinander zu
reden
das ist ein schöner gedanke deswegen
sollten wir jetzt vielleicht aufhören zu
reden richard wir hatten uns ein ganz
anderes thema vorgenommen jetzt eine
über freundschaft gesprochen und ich
fand's herrlich ich denke beim nächsten
mal sollten wir einfach mal die kunst
beherrschen 50 minuten miteinander zu
schweigen ist
ja immer vor was von ein traum wenn das
dann die erfolgreichste folge wird
absolut aber wir könnten dann was gegen
das klischee machen dass wir beide in
venedig
es gab früher bei radio hamburg hatte
ich immer ein chef
thomas walther doktor thomas weil er ein
großartiger journalist der hat in dem
zusammenhang immer gerne von
dampfplauderer gesprochen
genau
stammt ein schöner begriff osten 70 der
dampf dampfplauderer ist in der zeit als
es schreckschrauben und hupfdohlen gab
dampfplauderer ulknudeln
ein glossar der 70er jahre und
dampfplauderer ich glaube dass der
prototyp war dieter thomas heck wieder
erklangen klar der schnellsprecher und
dann und dann gab es auch noch wer war
denn die ulknudel war doch immer ried
steht ingrid steeger exakt nun suchen
wir
wollen nicht darüber nach röbel
balancen begriff den man heute finde ich
wieder gut gebrauchen kann also es sind
finde ich finde es ist eine elegante
beleidigen absolut und toni und felix
groß verdanken wir das revival von
colo colo also wunderbar bratpfanne und
kokolores und lange sind sie in der
richard ich danke dir sehr dicht bei auf
bis beim tatort ab
[Musik]
eine produktion von mpeg 2 und popstars
bei homer im auftrag des zdf
[Musik]